from the northwest to the south
spaniards are sweltering
in the andalusia region the mercury
soared to
45.6 degrees celsius on wednesday
the government is warning people to be
cautious and avoid going outdoors unless
absolutely necessary
with so much heat people don't leave
their home so early so there are no
customers until later in the day
this is the second heat wave in western
europe in a matter of weeks
forest fires are burning near the border
with portugal and northwest of madrid
where hundreds of residents have had to
leave their homes france and portugal
are also battling wildfires and at least
one person has died
there is a drought in spain water
reserves have shrunk more than 20
percent this year
we say to ourselves but how are we going
to end up either we see a lack of water
or a desert
it's not so much for us but for our
children and grandchildren
the conditions have made it impossible
for barley and wheat farmers to take
full advantage of the rising cost of
cereals
there would be a loss of 30 to 40
percent and in some areas of the
province of lida we're talking about 60
70 80 percent loss
meteorologists say climate change is
making both drought and heat waves more
frequent spaniards aren't expected to
get much relief from the high
temperatures until sunday
natasha nadine al jazeera